and we've counted at least three
possibly four victims that we've seen
again sustaining some type of injuries
you can see down below for students they
were being escorted by armed sheriff's
deputies down below here off the campus
here we say this school is on lockdown
it's a lockdown in describing that the
students are told to hold in place until
deputies arrived at their classroom so
they can clear a demon's safe and escort
kids out they want to evacuate this area
as quickly as possible now some of the
elementary schools nearby perhaps
students were just arriving for classes
hadn't even started and they were able
to hold those kids back that's unclear
at this time but I'll tell you what I
have yet to see a turnout than the Los
Angeles County Sheriff's Department like
I have with this incident for obvious
reasons you could see the amount of
deputies swarming this campus here we're
unable to see anything from our vantage
point about an individual being
surrounded or detained between this
campus and the nearby al